well time is running out to buy Mega
Millions tickets before tonight's
historic drawing the pot is up to a cool
nine hundred and seventy million dollars
that's a five hundred and forty eight
million dollar cash payout not too
shabby
Michelle likes it it's the largest Mega
Millions jackpot ever and the
second-largest lottery in history
there's also a four hundred and thirty
million dollar Powerball drawing
Saturday CBS this morning Saturday
co-host the other one Jacobson is in New
York at Manhattan motorcars Dana good
morning guys I mean just imagine if your
ticket like this one is a winner and you
take home that jackpot
all of this could be yours with the
pre-tax payout a room full of
Lamborghinis no need to pick a color and
the best part is you'll still have
enough left over to buy the exact same
room for six hundred forty five of your
closest friends this is that excitement
when you caught a look at the numbers
and your heart is pitter-pattering
millions are lining up like this across
the country for their chance to strike
it rich in tonight's historic 970
million dollar Mega Millions jackpot oh
this is a big one right here CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger our
obsession with lotteries with gambling
is that Unicorn feeling of like maybe
it'll be me last year Mega Millions
bunked its minimum jackpot up to 40
million dollars and increased the number
of balls from 15 to 25 the result larger
prizes and increased odds the chance of
winning jumped from one in roughly 258
million to one in 302 million this
drawing for perspective you're more than
twenty five thousand times more likely
to shoot a hole-in-one on the golf
course he's gonna get start writing
somebody's gonna win the lottery
Schlessinger points out some people
don't necessarily play to win they just
want to take a moment out of their day
to consider had a dream big and
Americans love doing just that about
two-thirds of us gamble last year we
spent nearly 73 billion dollars on
traditional lottery tickets on average
that's more than
hundred dollars per person instead of
spending two hundred dollars a year on
lottery tickets maybe we could encourage
people to say okay why not spend ten or
twenty bucks a year take the rest of the
money and maybe pay down some
outstanding credit card bills I don't
want to take away your dream I just want
to limit it and while we just keep
dreaming about actually owning a car
like this one with its quarter of a
million dollar price tag here's a more
practical number the revenue from the
lottery here in New York actually goes
to help education programs and that
meant three point three seven billion
dollars for New York schools last year
now nor as for tonight's drawing there's
good news if you don't just want nine
hundred seventy million dollars the
jackpot could still go up that decision
is coming later today Dana thank you and
it is 719 much more news